io sono giovanni caturano o sono co
fondatore di un'azienda che si chiama
skin vector che fa videogiochi e poi
cerca di unire digitale materiale ha
detto qualcuno prima
questo è stato il mio primo computer
faticosamente ottenuto dei miei genitori
e quello che ci facevo quando stavo
insieme viso e quello che faceva quasi
sempre soprattutto in mano i miei amici
era questo fondamentalmente ma quello
che facevo io prevalentemente con queste
computer assomiglia di più a questo un
po meno colorato da vedere ma
estremamente interessante per me perché
io ti volevo fare i videogiochi nel
senso di crearli e perché hurley dovevo
imparare a programmare e programmare
significa fare software ma il software
che cos'è il software è un sistema
digitale in cui il computer pensa un
pochino al posto nostro per risolvere
problemi problemi che esistono fuori dal
computer
vediamo un immagine di controllo del
traffico aereo controllo del traffico
era serve a non far bene tra di loro gli
aerei ieri stanno fuori dal computer
fuori dal software un programma di
videoscrittura mi serve per creare un
documento che magari devo stampare devo
inviare in digitale per risolvere un
problema fuori dal software devo
costruire una casa uso un software che
mi aiuta a costruire quella casa che poi
sarà un oggetto che sta in giro che sta
da qualche parte vero fuori dal computer
e fuori dal software e il software mi
devi aiutare a fare per far fare queste
cose quanto più efficientemente
possibile quindi arrivare al risultato
migliore e più breve tempo possibile
questa è l'efficienza cioè se ho un
problema è una soluzione il punto a al
punto b o degli ostacoli devo trovare
una traiettoria per arrivare dal
problema
la soluzione ma la voglio anche più
rapida e più veloce possibile meno
costosa possibile
devo fare subito e bene ok questo ce lo
insegnano ed è la radice del business
quello che fa fare i soldi così ci
insegnano a scuola così da insegnare a
me per programmare ma si può applicare a
tutti problema applicare l'efficienza al
videogioco il paradigma che abbiamo
appena visto proviamo proviamoci con un
gioco famoso mario abbiamo mario il
manager lo vetero e dicono ok ragazzi
qual è il problema
che problema c'è da risolvere qui c'è
una principessa che si chiama vince che
è stata rapita e mario la deve salvare
facciamo in modo efficiente allora i
programmatori si riuniscono i designer
si riuniscono e questo menù che si usa
per iniziare a giocare lo cambierà
diventa così salva pc adesso il
giocatore preme il tasto
bravo mario ha salvato la principessa e
quanto ci siamo divertiti
non moltissimo perché nei videogiochi
diversamente da tutto il resto del
software il problem solving e demandato
all'uomo non ci piace il videogioco si
risolve il problema al posto nostro
il videogioco fa problemi king se
finiamo usare questa questa espressione
e le persone pagano per avere problemi
i giocatori il giocatore che sono tra
voi pagano per avere un videogioco che
un software che gli crea dei problemi
qualcuno pensava che in questo momento
vedo le faccia sì ma io ho anche i
software che mi dovrebbe risolvere i
problemi in veneta e l'ho pagato ancora
di più è vero per ora si sente che i
videogiochi sono progettati apposta
perché avrei problemi
un discorso un pochettino differente da
quello che succede in quei casi allora
si paga si paga bene tenete conto che il
90 per cento dei soldi fatti sugli app
store sono videogiochi quindi insomma
non è male come di un giro di mercato in
business più grande della musica per
esempio del del cinema dell'home video
paghiamo e investiamo del tempo e
dedichiamo tantissima energia noi
giocatori per imparare risolvere i
problemi perché ci divertiamo e perché
l'apprendimento il divertimento sono
esattamente la stessa cosa lo dice raf
coaster uno dei miei studiosi del
settore preferiti e questa è una cosa
che noi sappiamo fin da bambini e
naturale per noi lo sappiamo quando
siamo piccoli quando diventiamo grandi
tendiamo un po a dimenticarlo e ci
comportiamo come si comporta l'androide
data queste star trek e selection che
vuole sapere che cosa si prova a essere
bambini e quello che sa la sua destra i
dice che per capirlo bisogna giocare un
po tutti i giorni bisogna divertirsi un
po tutti i giorni allora si arriva a
quel tipo di apprendimento divertimento
che è naturale
non perdete il latino ludus che
significa gioco significa anche scuola e
ce lo ricordiamo spesso allora se ci
rivolgiamo un po alla natura capiamo che
questo è vero e lo capiamo guardando per
esempio i gatti
questo dato non è qui soltanto perché i
gatti portano click
ma ovviamente anche questo è vero e il
gatto del nostro ufficio si chiama molli
e lo spin gatto che usa i 600 metri
quadri del nostro ufficio come un enorme
parco giochi e giocando impara il gioco
è una simulazione delle attività reali
senza la gravità delle conseguenze
il gioco e come un'attività verona ci
può riprovare se sbagliano
io sono quello che nell'esempio del
treno di prima ha pensato direttamente
beh io la prima volta lo farei andare
così vedere cosa succede questo sempre
videogiochi tanto poi muori ripeti poi
provi a tirare una leva e magari riesce
ad aver il tempo di slegare il
poveraccio questa seminari e quindi
riesce a salvare tutti questa è la
differenza tra gioco e vita reale e così
si apprende e così fanno i gatti così
fanno tutti gli animali superiori tutti
i mammiferi ma anche molti altri animali
invece per esempio le formiche no le
formiche quando nascono già sono tutto
quello che gli serve per vivere e se noi
riusciamo ad apprendere in questo modo
diventiamo degli individui migliori e
diventando degli individui migliori
riusciamo poi ad ottenere qualsiasi
obiettivo riusciamo a raggiungere
qualsiasi obiettivo che per esempio per
i gatti è a occupare tutte le nostre
poltrone
ovviamente no come sa chiunque ha un
gatto e vedo che due persone almeno
hanno colto anche la citazione ora
perché il divertimento è potente
potente perché è la leva principale
siccome connaturata e noi è la leva
principale che ci fa muovere e ci fa
fare tante cose per esempio questa
questa è la strada tra roma e il mio
ufficio tra il centro di roma il mio
ufficio passando per napoli è un gruppo
di persone
un giorno si è fatta questi 317 km ci
vuole ore e un quarto se sei fortunato
per fare una cosa strana io ho ricevuto
una notifica sul mio cellulare che il
portale in un gioco del mio ufficio era
sotto attacco ma sotto un attacco
massiccio un attacco che solo poche
persone in italia potevano fare e ce ne
volevano 8 di quelle persone una l'ho
vista prima che stava qui adesso non sa
dove sta e due di quelle sono venute
della roma sono venute per tracciare
questa linea vedete questa linea verde
qui sopra per tracciare questa linea
collegare un portale al centro di roma
con un portale del mio ufficio per la
prima volta creare un campo di controllo
intercontinentale di cui ha parlato il
telegiornale di questo videogioco che è
un videogioco di google che si chiama
ingressi e questo è il servizio di
queste le giornale non hanno avuto un
euro non hanno avuto un buono spesa non
ho avuto nemmeno un panino e se ne sono
andati via io sono arrivato nel
frattempo ma non potevo niente allora
sono troppo potenti come giocatori
quattro di loro gli ha offerto una birra
ma i romani se ne sono andati subito
perché dovevano tornare a casa alle
nostre tre ore di viaggio davanti al
loro credo fossero le dieci e mezzo agli
undici di sera stasera sarà peggio per
me e quindi di questo vi dà un'idea di
quanto sia motivante videogioco e ci
faccia fare delle cose che altrimenti
non riescono
questo era capito bene una società che
fa
software di navigazione gps si chiama
wei wei s'è trasformata la navigazione
gps in gioco dando al giocatore non dei
buoni benzina come aveva provato a fare
qualcun altro prima ma dei pupazzetti la
spada lo scudo un titolo la macchinetta
diversa se per esempio gli verificavano
le mappe voi andreste in giro adesso vi
sentite delle strade qua fuori mettete
verificare un po tutte le strade allora
hanno messo dei puntini in mezzo alla
strada e per il accoglimi come pacco era
avuto un successo incredibile sono il
principale provider di dati sul traffico
e sugli incidenti e sui problemi
stradali del mondo e google se li ha
comprati per qualcosa come un miliardo e
non so quante centinaia di milioni di
dollari quindi vedete che anche una cosa
che poi funziona a livello a livello
economico perché tutto questo perché il
divertimento non ha bisogno di
giustificazioni se io ti voglio
convincere a fare qualcosa perché giusta
fatico lavoro ci mettono a segno questo
sì ma io la vedo questa trovata
direttamente divertimento guardate
questi giochi pensate pac man
pensa se qualcuno di voi lo ricorda
nelle nelle anche con nessuno si
chiedeva ma che cos'è questa faccia
gialla che apre e chiude la bocca per
quale motivo deve andare a raccogliere
questi punti 10 sono questi fantasmi gli
spettri di chi i blocchi di tetris che
ti chiedeva marchi di fabbrica perché
devo distruggerli avranno un anima ti
diverti lo fai per passare un gioco più
moderno piante contro zombi perché gli
zombie dovrebbero attaccare solo il mio
giardino io dovrei difendermi con delle
piante e chi se ne frega e divertente
ora applicare i principi del gioco ha un
altra attività umana si chiama
gamification io credo che in questo
momento stiamo arrivando a quella che io
chiamo reali fi che sono cioè la realtà
sfrutta i videogiochi le conseguenze
delle azioni della realtà vanno a fini
e nei videogiochi se noi riusciamo io
sto iniziando come una rete di aziende a
fare questo percorso
se riusciamo a fare dei veri videogiochi
veramente divertente non nei giochini
appiccicati e delle attività ma dei
giochi divertenti in cui tu vedi le
conseguenze di questa attività e giochi
divertenti
io ho l'orgoglio di avere un team di
lisa fare bene abbiamo circa 3 milioni
di giocatori abbiamo vinto un po di
parenti ma qua ci sono altri
sviluppatori di videogiochi almeno
qualcuno lo vedo c'è un rappresentante
rimanga tarli di fronte che adesso
stanno in 119 paesi in prima pagina
sulla storia
complimenti se noi riusciamo a fare
questo possiamo cambiare i nostri
comportamenti li possiamo cambiare per
esempio del nostro essere dei buoni
cittadini con lo smartphone ma anche con
applicazioni di cittadinanza digitale
che ci fanno che ci premiano quando poi
lo abbiamo dei comportamenti buoni per
esempio con la raccolta differenziata e
ci premiano in un gioco che sia
veramente in gioco e se riusciamo a fare
questo possiamo per esempio risparmiare
energia risparmiare energia
collegandoci il collegato del videogioco
alla nostra casa intelligente e vedendo
qual è il nostro progressione metteteci
competizione con i nostri vicini perché
no
e se risparmiamo energia evidentemente
abbiamo un ambiente migliore un ambiente
migliore significa stare in un contesto
dove l'aria è pulita dove le altre
persone stanno meglio e quindi dove
migliora la nostra salute e quella che
già teniamo sott'occhio con gli smart
work che ci dicono quanti passi abbiamo
fatto oggi sono sotto par 3.500 circa
e che ci stimolano a fare qualcosa in
più per mantenerci bene tutto questo ci
permette di migliorare se ne riusciamo a
migliorare noi e metterci in
competizione in cooperazione con i
nostri vicini con questi strumenti
possiamo divertirci e nello stesso tempo
salvarci e se riusciamo a salvarci
possiamo salvare il pianeta grazie